ghost runner has been marketed as an
action game with fast-paced combat but i
didn't expect that they also meant the
story as well within seconds of playing
so much is given to the player it's
almost
overwhelming and it's not some sad
attempt at the devs to cram in the story
it's completely intentional and it's
done on purpose and for good reason
today we're going to be discussing the
story of ghost runner from beginning to
end obviously there's going to be
spoilers ahead so i highly recommend you
beat the game first and then come back
going back to the previous statement
though within seconds we take in this
amount of information rather fully
robotic or at least part robotic being
someone is talking in our head and we
just killed a man in cold blood with a
sword some obvious first
responses should be how did we get here
who are we in
why are we here all very valid questions
allow me to give you a brief rundown of
all the information given to us about
what
happened before we got to this exact
point humanity was living a normal life
but something called the burst occurred
on september 26th
of 2156 it's unclear what happened and
what caused it but it wiped out lots of
the human population
the ceo billionaire adam hamada had
predicted an astronomical event that
would occur in the near future because
of this he created a giant tower called
the dharma tower built to house hundreds
of thousands of people away from the
inevitable apocalypse and to keep the
human species alive the setting of the
whole ghost runner game is played inside
the tower because the burst wiping out
most of humanity's creations and its
history
a lot of the world resorted to new ways
artifacts of the old world as it's
called can still be found within the
tower as the refugees were bringing them
along with them either for practical or
sentimental
purposes the leader of the tower was as
expected the creator adam hamada but we
know him as the architect adam is
becoming very old one of the audio logs
says that he's about 95 at one point and
this was even before we arrived in this
world so he's still a very old person
that leads to the next question who
exactly are we
well adam puts it as a series of
connected implants
people in the tower have cybernetic
implants eyesight robotic limbs etc we
are a bunch of those implants connected
together or in a simplified version
we're a robot this is told in a
roundabout way as we never see our face
and while we do have human features in
human extremities they seem to be all
mechanical and adam mentioned that we
seem to have feelings of empathy and
other emotions which as a robot you
aren't supposed to develop these on top
of that later in the game
jack asks adam who were the ghost
runners before they were ghost runners
and adam said that there was no before
all they ever have been was ghost
runners and that was it all proving we
are indeed fully robotic with no human
descent
audio log 3 mentions a ghost runner
project and since we are considered a
ghost runner
this is how we were made adam tried for
quite a while to get the correct first
ghost runner many had failed before us
some robots committed suicide and some
had severe mental instability he also
mentions a woman named maro which we
know is the antagonist of the tower and
the woman we need to kill
but he mentions her in a light-hearted
way very different from his usual banter
about her
when he is in our heads this means that
they were at the very minimum colleagues
that worked together those runners were
meant to be guards peacekeepers or at
some points whatever adam wanted us to
be
and be seen as the good guys keeping the
law in order in the tower
they were equal but not identical some
ghost runners were made differently
housing different abilities and sadly we
didn't get any of those
we're just a basic ghost runner at its
core later adam was able to have a
conversation with himself so to speak
attempt number 22 was just able to
repeat adam's beliefs that he had just
mentioned to him and not only that
but he also understood the different
statuses of being or as adam called it
ontonology which is a branch of
metaphysics dealing with the nature of
being i don't really need to go into all
of that as it's super confusing but
regardless this shows that adam is
making progress
sadly it tried to take over the cyber
void so adam had to pull the plug and
kill it
implying a kill switch for the robot
does work and is indeed a thing they
have august 24th
2235 79 years after the burst had
occurred was a big leap as he officially
created the first fully sentient
artificial intelligence that was
able to do his bidding and carry out his
plans when he died
he named this the architect so adam was
human he was aware of course of his
mortality and decided to prevent that in
a roundabout way by making a sentient ai
that is exactly like him sharing the
same beliefs and goals for the success
of the tower
except he didn't have to worry about the
mortality of any of the struggles that
came with being human he did this as he
believed the plan for the tower and the
survival of the species was the only way
and wanted to prevent people from
enacting their own plans and driving the
species into extinction the last audio
log is 100 year old adam drunk talking
about how the architect and mara planned
to kill him in sabotage's plan
well at the very least he was half right
eventually a coup would start 20 years
prior to the first mission of ghost
runner
mara would then kill adam and deactivate
majority of the ghost runners while the
others that didn't deactivate
immediately
were killed we of course were one of
them being gr74
there were 100 ghost runners and we were
the only survivor but
barely maro was then known as the
keymaster
she adopted this name as she believes
she's going to unlock the chains of the
people and set everyone free
adam and mara have two different ways of
living adam believes in the one true
iron will
in order to preserve the species and to
do that we have to maintain the
functioning of the tower to continue to
stay inside
mara wants everyone to go outside and
escape this prison known as the tower
we'll get into the complication of both
their plans at the later part of the
video
but just keep that in mind us as gr74 or
jack end up falling from dharma city to
the base district throughout the game we
are climbing
the tower and we fell that whole way
down which is a quite of a drop the
tower has two main parts the base and
the city district
the base district is the poor area of
the tower while the city district is for
the rich people the base residents are
called basers and they're doing pretty
well at the start but it slowly got
worse as the rations they were provided
slowly got less and less in quantity
factory workers and miners were the only
people that actually got rations
the rest had a scavenge and make do some
of the basers figured out how to grow
food inside the tower but it required
tons of chemicals and lots of trials it
wasn't perfect but it was better than
nothing
the conditions sucked down in the base
district with constant chemicals and
heavy machinery
it wasn't too great to breathe in so a
rebreather was always required in the
base district
the reason the baser survived it all was
mostly due to the black market
where people could sell illegal goods
and food so people could survive
and because of the black market the base
district had many criminals and because
of the many criminals
sometimes the ghost runners had to step
in as security down there some of the
items in the black market included drugs
and weapons firearms were only wielded
by the key master guard so if somebody
had a firearm on them they were either a
guard or they killed one after the
killing of the ghost runners people
started scavenging their swords they
were a fortune but they were as deadly
as they come
alternatively if you were low on funds a
standard issue butterfly knife would
work too
most people carried these around as they
were cheap compared to the other
alternatives and the people in the base
district always needed protection
as you never know who wanted something
that you had the two districts in the
game were distinctly different for all
the wrong reasons
the base district is where we start at
the beginning of the game without even
getting a story recap or flashback of
what has happened we're already thrusted
into the action and that's intentional
our ghost runner jack doesn't know what
happened and neither do we
so it's like we're experiencing
everything along with him the first two
levels are more
of a tutorial so jack can get used to
his cybernetic implants again
eventually make it to the president
ourselves and release the architect this
whisper on our head has been a giant ai
head this entire time
he then shoots us into the cyber void
cyber vote is like a neural network it
was supposed
to be all connected at once but because
of mara and the coup it's split and
broken into pieces which is why we can't
access all the points of cyber void the
first time we use it and we have to go
to the different areas to get new
upgrades this is where we find out about
the climbers and how they repaired us
they're a typical gang like any other
base district no different from any
other gangs that exist
except they do have some reputable
ideals like opposing the key master the
climbers somehow stumbled upon our dead
body
and found some of our hardware and put
us back together thankfully they missed
a few of the pieces as one of them was
the kill switch
that adam and mara had put in the ghost
runners should an uprising happen
but mara exploited it and used it to
kill most of the ghost runners before
they got a chance to stop her coup
that's why it was so successful and
since they didn't find it that means
that we are safe from an immediate
shutdown
this is where we meet zoe the only
climber left she was rebuilding us along
with others the climbers gave us our
name
jack as our hardware was quote jacked up
they tried everything they could but
they couldn't wake us up
that was because adam was waiting for
the proper time to wake us up once all
the hardware was put back into place and
we were semi-functional again but as we
mentioned she was the only one left
mara and her guards ended up ambushing
the hideouts of the climbers zoe ended
up leaving and escaping as she was the
only survivor
afterwards we continue on to the next
mainframe and we get a huge amount of
foreshadow
where adam mentions that without the
cyber void adam doesn't exist and
without adam
we don't exist so in a way without the
cyber void we don't exist
major foreshadowing of the events to
come originally the plan was to slowly
climb up the tower and kill
mara easy peasy but zoe mentions that
the keymaster guards are withdrawing her
forces in some of the sectors we soon
come to find out
this is because she is shutting down the
air filters in one of the sectors
one thing the tower can do is filter the
terrible air quality of the outside
and put all the good air inside but
without those filters the toxic air
seeps in and will kill everyone in the
sector
she's doing this to make an example of
the other sectors to keep the other ones
in line
that's just how the base district works
this is part of a huge turning point for
the game as
weird as it sounds adam shows his true
intentions by bringing up how sometimes
sacrifice is necessary for the majority
to survive as long as the tower is
prospering
any amount of sacrifice is worth it as
long as it's the minority as adam puts
it we weren't designed to put the needs
of the few over the needs of the many
this also shows that even though we are
fully robotic we're starting to develop
emotions which is very out of place
and adam had not intended for this to
happen jack brings up a good point
though
if mara wanted to make an example out of
the sector then she would have just
broken the air filters and prevent any
types of repairs
the reason mara does this is not because
she cares about the people but it's
because the people that are there are
basically human production lines and she
uses them as tools so the city district
can survive it's very apparent for mara
that while she does care about the
people of the tower it's not because
they're just people
and the human species it's more because
they are just efficiency workers that
will help prosper the tower we finally
make it to the next mainframe connecting
the air filters here we learn about the
cyber void and how it's connected to
everything in dharma tower and it's
basically a huge network with the
mainframe finished up the air filters
are back online and the sector 5 and its
residents continue to live mara also
shut down the central elevator so we
have to find the control terminal to get
up to the city district in a different
way
this is just as simple as finding the
cyber void mainframe again then
connecting to it physically bypassing
the wall and
we're in we then see a disturbance
nearby which is the laser array t073m
or tom beating tom is a tough one who
has three phases all of which are very
complicated
tom is easily the hardest boss this game
has due to how much you have to pay
attention to every single laser and
firewall that exists in the area this
machine is basically a giant defense
system for people who are planning an
uprising it sounds like adam was
expecting an uprising but that wasn't
the case
he even states that he wasn't expecting
one but he built tom just in case there
was one
once tom is defeated we take the
elevator and we're now in dharma city
as we stated the city district is more
for the privileged and the rich
before mara ruled there was an exam adam
had which was a way for people to move
up into the city district from the base
district it's unsure if mara kept the
same system when she was ruler but
regardless both
mara and adam both allowed very little
people to live this high up in the tower
only the loyal and the worthy were
allowed now that we've made it to the
city our next goal is the repository
we also learn in this section why we use
swords and not guns which is a pretty
valid question and that's due to the
fact that there's no collateral damage
no stray bullets and no mechanical
issues with the sword it's very simple
within the cyber vote of the repository
we discover a bit more info about the
actual ghost runner project
it used to be a military contract but
then turned into something way bigger
mara and adam had both co-operated the
project adam handled the logistics and
mara made the design of us
as we approached the repository we sent
a slight disturbance and apparently
according to zoe
some of the cameras are being blinded by
some sort of interference that
disturbance ends up being another ghost
runner well
technically it is and it isn't a ghost
runner it's not the original ghost
runner it's more of a newer version of
it made by mara
it's unclear why there's only one when
the contract with adam she had 100
but i guess she was maybe confident in
her abilities to prevent an uprising and
keep the peace so she only needed one
i doubt this thing was actually
specifically made to kill us i think
that's more of an added bonus as these
things can really not be mass-produced
so she must have built this before we
were alive while chasing this ghost
runner we see a train which is fast
enough to catch up with her we then make
it to her
and start the second boss fight her name
is hell and as we said this is mara's
guard or ghost runner version the hell
boss
fight is pretty easy and can be done
fairly quickly so there's not much to it
we end up taking some of the data intact
from her head
and takes some of her abilities this
level also brings up a pretty good point
zoe mentions to us that we and her are
pretty similar we're the last of our
people and we chose to fight against the
oppression of mara
while she's not wrong she's technically
is as we were programmed to fight and
obey
we're not programmed to do anything else
so technically us uprising against the
oppression of mara
was technically not our choice
eventually we end up reaching the lab
where we're introduced to more unique
enemies they have these synthetic
respiratory systems and fake skin
surrounding most of the body and no
brain
these aren't even humans anymore which
is definitely not okay
we then find our last cyber void
mainframe and get our last ability but
it's slightly concerning as we're
hacking the atmoship of the person and
turning them against their friends
this means that adam knows how to hack
into people's minds which while he never
used it the fact that he knows it exists
is an issue as he can do what he pleases
with that knowledge
jack says that adam is worse than mara
as maro only sabotaged the ghost runners
where adam has the potential to sabotage
other people
and maybe he's right it's more of a
debatable argument
we then reach a larger laboratory which
according to adam houses the world's
brightest minds most of them were here
before the cataclysm and to save their
expertise
adam knew he couldn't save everyone but
at least he could save the best
we're slowly starting to understand
adam's whole plan bit by bit
one thing that continues to come up more
and more is that we get into the later
levels
is the questioning of jack before in the
first couple levels all jack would
really do would just obey and do what he
was doing but now when adam brings up
the negatives of mara like how her plan
is so terrible for the species
he'll start to question adam as well on
the same topic like if mara's plan is so
bad then that must mean his plan is good
but jack doesn't know his plan so he
asks him and adam refuses to respond as
adam knows that if he does say
what his true intentions are then jack
won't obey him adam has been noticing
jack was losing his usual robot mind
and becoming more human-esque as we're
developing emotions and you can tell
he's trying to prevent jack from
thinking too much and keeping us in line
as he's constantly talking to us and
saying how good his plan is and how
terrible of a person mara is
but it's really zoe who opens us up
someone not of a higher power and just a
normal citizen who isn't ordering us
around and
sometimes understands that we don't need
to do everything she asks
she briefly mentioned the people dying
in sector 5 and jack voluntarily helped
with the toxic filters
he was never forced to do any of this
and he did this completely on his own
mara was noticing this as well and she
questioned adam as why we even had to
save the fifth sector anyway and she was
mentioning how we must have a mind of
our own and she's right as adam was
completely against the idea the entire
time
mars starts to reveal more about adam
and his plan saying how we're just pawns
and that
adam wanted to make something stronger
than humans but they were slaves
inexpendable
and at this point the questioning is
getting pretty bad this place is special
you
lied to me jack is not even asking adam
questions to try to get information he's
just simply becoming more irritated with
him and not even bothering
truly showing jack's evolution of his
mind which is way different than it was
in the first mission
we eventually come to meet mara and
after defeating her adam talks about how
jack fulfilled his purpose and how we
can start with the next part of the plan
every time we upgraded and connected to
those mainframes not only were we making
ourselves stronger but we were making
him stronger and now he can reach
different areas of the tower and
eventually be able to fully be back and
control the systems of the tower except
not in a human
as an ai once we go through all of the
cyber void though and officially make it
to adam
he does try to stop us this ending
cutscene is pretty revolutionary as
it's huge for jack he doesn't want to go
by his ghost runner name anymore he
wants to go by his human name that zoe
gave him
without him defeated the tower now has
no ruler but because cyber void is gone
as we severed the connection so too are
we
since as we stated before without cyber
void adam doesn't exist and without adam
we don't exist so in a way without the
cyber void we don't exist things were a
bit spread out in terms of the
information of their planning so
let's just recap exactly what both of
their plans were mars plan was those
creatures synthetic beings with no mind
just
emotionless bodies not human but able to
walk the surface of the planet again
without being in the tower
as adam puts it mara doesn't care about
the side effects of her testing
she doesn't even care about their sanity
only their efficiency for obvious
reasons this is a terrible idea which is
why she needed to be stopped
adam or the architect's plan is about
how we are just tools for something
greater
saying that as long as we preserve the
tower everything will be okay
and if a small amount of people die to
help the majority so be it
he also mentions that everyone will be
eating sleeping breathing and breeding
according to the needs of the tower
in a way if we have no control over what
we do in our day-to-day life doesn't
that just make us the same emotional as
creatures that mara was creating
except this point we look more human
both of their plans are the same but
slightly altered to fit their specific
needs
mara wants to leave the tower adam wants
to stay in it
both of their plans involve using the
people of dharma as pawns in their
experiments and the two don't see the
error of their plans as they think it's
for the greater good
but they're both delusional as both of
their plans have the same outcome
none of them really cared for the people
only themselves and this illusion that
they were helping humanity when in
reality
they weren't humanity is full of humans
with emotion being able to think for
themselves and do as they please
these are not humans they're just
creatures zoe i think put it really well
at the end of the game
saying adam and mara wanted to be gods
with the citizens being their playthings
but they overreached which got them
killed and i think that's completely
true
i've heard a lot of people discuss the
very very ending cutscene which is jack
dying but then him gripping the sword
proving he still has some life in him
and while i think that's valid
i don't really think that's too
important as the outcome of our actions
is what is more important
if we actually lived that's fantastic
but if we died then it's tragic but we
also helped humanity not be tied down by
tyrants
and in some way either option is a win
for the human race it said that jack
would die when he finally got to feel
human even though he's not
but he at least can say that he was
human even for a little bit of time
and not some mindless machine like the
first couple missions
and that's the story of ghost honor
thank y'all for joining me on this
journey let me know how you like to go
throw under in the comments down below
it was shorter than most games i've
played but it was a blast every minute
of the way
like the video if you enjoyed the
commentaries i have many story videos
planned for future games
and an interesting video coming out
within a week or so that is probably one
of the best videos i've ever made in my
five years on youtube and
also an upcoming series regardless thank
you for watching
like and subscribe and hopefully i'll
see you in a future video goodbye
[Music]
you